[Music]
we have a lot to cover with you today we
have a bunch of really cool guest
speakers that are going to bring stories
and we're going to focus today about
speech to text and speech recognition so
speech text is part of our conversation
group of products in our building blocks
as part of card a I you know we have a
very large portfolio of AI solutions
that are you know all of them pretty
much leading in their space so we
definitely recommend if you if you have
some time to check out some of the other
sessions about the other products a lot
of a lot of cool stuff being announced
yesterday and today at next so how many
people here were at our Google cloud
next session last year on speech-to-text
ok a few of you so it's hard to believe
but last year when we were here the
product was still in beta so we actually
only announced GA just over a year ago
in April 2017 and you know long form
recognition the product has gone through
so much since then
we've added 30 new languages we're now
at 120 languages you know mind-boggling
and a bunch of other features like you
know time stands like punctuation and
and the new models which we'll talk
about later there's two main use cases
that we address speech for
human-computer interaction and speech
analytics human-computer interaction is
typically one person talking to a
computer and then a computer reacting to
it either voice search or voice actions
or things like that speech analytics is
analyzing conversations between
different humans it could be in a phone
call it could be in a meeting so we're
going to sort of structure the
conversation today
two sets of use cases so today we're
we're introducing four new beta features
or actually yesterday language ID
multi-channel recognition speaker
dilation word level confidence we're
going to talk more about each of them so
well well we'll come back to them but
they all make speech-to-text much much
more useful and practical for the virus
use cases that it solves so let's focus
on the first set of use cases first so
human-computer interaction when you want
to use speech recognition to power sort
of different apps or solutions so there
we are new feature we're introducing for
that is language ID so like you can see
on the right on that screenshot for
Google search if you if you use voice
search you can select multiple different
languages so it's not a radio button
it's sort of checkboxes and you can
check as many as you want and then when
you speak to it it can understand which
language you're talking and and and it
recognizes the the transcription in that
language so we're now making that
available in the API you just send
multiple language codes we figure out
which one is the right one and we return
the transcript in that language it works
pretty well but it's still not perfect
so if you actually know the language
code in advance you're always better off
just supplying it but if you don't know
and you have multiple it's going to do a
kind of a best efforts job at figuring
out which language it was it's currently
optimized for voice search and voice
commands so we we recommend using it for
those kinds of use cases for now okay
and then for speech analytics the the
second set of use cases we have that's
where the other three features where
we're introducing today are focused so
let's talk a little bit more about those
so you know speech recognition for for
people that are new to the space it
sounds you know pretty similar right
you're trying to recognize what someone
said it sounds like a consistent set of
problems that you're solving
but can actually be quite different so
if you look at recognizing a video
versus recognizing a phonecall versus
recognizing a command so an example of a
video could be a basketball game and you
know you could be you could have sounds
of the different players that are
playing sounds of the actual basketball
bouncing on the ground
sounds of sorry the TV hosts that are
sort of interrupting sounds of the
advertisements that are playing and the
you know the number of speakers could be
four or more it could be even like
twenty or thirty or forty depending on
how many advertisements are there there
could be kind of lots of background
noises and it could be many hours long
if you look at phone calls there it's
it's usually going to be you know
handful of speakers and the backgrounds
there it's gonna be more static from the
phone line or you know compression
that's used or a narrower sampling rate
like eight kilohertz and it's usually
gonna be a few minutes long and then if
you look at a command you know it's
usually just one speaker a few seconds
and there's you know there could be a
lot of background noise but it's very
very different in nature it's going to
be other people talking or music or
other things playing in the background
sort of the a lot of Google's speech
recognition efforts were originally
focused on the right hand side on sort
of voice searches and voice commands but
one of the kind of top requests we got
from cloud customers is to solve more of
the problems on the on the left and so
that's where in April we introduced our
new our new models so we now have four
models that you can choose from phone
call video voice commands and and
default and they each you know are tuned
to perform really well for that set of
use cases so you know voice commands is
is tuned to actually filter out all of
the other background speakers right
because
it's a it's built to recognize one
person and it assumes everything else
that's not the primary speaker it should
be filtered out versus our phone call
model is actually built to recognize you
know everyone that's talking in the
phone call that sounds like they're
they're part of the conversation so
they're they're kind of built with
different goals now a default model
that's been around for for a year or two
that we've gotten consistent customer
feedback that it's you know best in the
market it's best better than any other
vendor that's out there but you know
that was never kind of our aspiration we
we wanted to be not just better than
others but actually good and so you know
that's where we we came out with these
new models but what we were able to do
the video model is 64% less errors than
our default model that was considered
already best-in-class in the industry
and so you know you could argue that
it's three times as good as as anything
else that's out there and then the new
phone call model is fifty four percent
less errors and then our previous model
so you know twice as good as its what
existed before so we're very excited
about these new models and you know all
the new use cases that they open because
now that you can actually do speech
recognition for these mediums that's
that's pretty good there's all of this
all this set of analytics that you can
do that you can do before okay so today
we're introducing two new features in
the space speaker dilation and
multi-channel recognition so when you
have a conversation between multiple
people our recommendation is to record
them separately in separate channels and
there's two reasons for that one is the
accuracy of the transcription is going
to be better because it's even for
humans it's easier to understand each
speaker separately versus when they're
talking on top of each other
the other reason is it's also easier to
separate the speakers because you know
you don't really need to do anything
everything you can just figure out like
who spoke in each channel so for that if
you do have the speakers separated
that's where we were introducing
multi-channel recognition
can take an audio file that has multiple
channels and separate the different
channels and the speaker's there if
unfortunately not everyone has that
luxury of having the the audio file
separated into channels and so if you
only have a mono channel and you still
want to recognize multiple speakers
that's where we're now offering in beta
our speaker our new speaker dilation it
can separate multiple speakers in an
audio file but it's it's obviously not
going to be perfect right it's gonna
it's gonna do a kind of a best efforts
job because it's it's it's using machine
learning and doing it sort of by of
program versus external separation
either way we don't recognize that until
the person and we don't store the
information beyond the API call so you
know there's nothing here that's related
to identity so you know I'm going to
show you guys just an example
architecture of how this can be used in
speech analytics and then we'll do a
little bit of a code lab and you also
see another another example of it later
from one of our guest speakers so you
know you can imagine a set up where you
have audio coming in from a phone
gateway a lot of these foam gateways
were built many years ago and don't
really have the ability to separate
audio into different channels so it
comes out as mono and then it would go
to cloud speech-to-text that does the
transcription and the diary's ation and
then if you want to do cool things like
for example analyzing sentiment you
really want to analyze each speaker
separately right because what matters is
not the sort of the average of the both
but but each one as they were as though
we're talking so so you can analyze the
customer and the agent separately and
then feed each one into some analytics
engine like bigquery and then run
different analytics on on that data so
last but not least one other feature
work we're introducing there's word
level confidence it's been kind of one
of our top features
ice ve customers more sophisticated
customers what it does it gives you a
confidence go up until now like you can
see on the top you we had confidence
scores that were based on segments now
you actually get confident scores based
on the word so you can take more action
on it like we prompt in the user or
things like that okay so I'm going to
show you guys how to actually do this in
in Python bear in mind I'm not a very
good Python programmer so let's do this
together hopefully it will work if not
if not we'll solve it together actually
before we do that let's let me just show
you the sample file that we're gonna use
so this is the sample file let me play
it I hope the audio is connected I was
wondering whether you could help me with
that
certainly which color would you like we
have blue black and red let's go with
the black one would you like the new
chromecast vote remodel or the regular
compressed regular chromecast is fine
thank you okay sure
would you like to ship it regular or
Express Express please terrific it's on
the way thank you thank you very much
bye okay so that's the audio file
it's transcribing it now should be done
in a second and then we're gonna see the
results in four different models so in
the in the default model the phone model
the command model and video the the
video model is the best one for this
file well it's working what I'm going to
do next is I'm going to go to our Docs
and
I'm going to go to the speaker
dollarization example so it's this one
here in Python and let's view it on
github okay there it is okay so let's
look let's look at video so you can see
this is the transcription so
transcription is reasonably accurate
most of the time it's good like here you
can see or let's go with the black one
would you like new chromecast or a
regular Chrome cast regular chromecast
is fine thank you okay sure so you can
see it's kind of it's working most of
the time so let's go to a code editor
and we'll open this this code snippet we
saw here on github and let's let's try
and run it so python beta snippet
sterilization let's see if this works
what this should be doing is the same
thing we saw in the web transcribing it
and showing the results as well as the
as the dilation of the results
and then okay here it is so you can see
there's all of the words on each where
it has a speaker tag okay so what I want
to show you is how to actually get a
stream of text that's different for each
speaker and then take that stream of
text do some sentiment analysis and
print this course so before we do that
let's replace the speech file with
better one d harn documents code I know
I think it's me all you know this is the
name of it
what if okay then it's going to open the
file
oh sorry this is dog this was the wrong
one
it's just transcribed a file with
metadata here this conversation okay
we're going to use this file it's going
to read the file then recognition config
we don't need sample rate wouldn't
recognize it off automatically enables
Dyer ization speaker count let's also
add automatic punctuation so all we need
to do is just add this and I will start
punctuating and let's also use the video
model so here there's an example with
the model let's take this and add video
model here okay great and now instead of
printing all the words let's let's do
this let's do speaker 1 transcript and
speaker 2 transcript let's initialize
them and then let's ask if basically
this thing equals 1 then what we want to
do is take this speaker transcript and
add to it
this word and let's also add a space and
then if it's the second speaker tag we
want to do the same thing with speaker
to transcript and then let's do this
let's print transcript and let's put in
speaker transcript one okay then let's
do it again with second speaker
transcript transcript to transcript okay
let me save there's probably gonna be a
bunch of compilation errors but let's
let's work through them together
[Music]
okay I edited the right file we'll see
in a second so what we're expecting is
to see transcript one with all of the
words that the first person said and
transcript to with all of the words that
ii wrists it okay looks like it's
working so far so good guys
[Applause]
okay
so now let's look at the example for
analyzing sentiment so this is using
cloud natural language API I'm going to
go to this example on github and then
copy some code lines here so first in
terms of imports it needs all of this
import stuff so let's copy it over and
put it here on the top and we'll see our
parse is duplicates so we don't need
that one I think we still need the other
Oh out system sexy other different okay
so we have the imports and now sorry
this is probably too small let's copy
this piece that does sentiment analysis
and now we'll paste it in here and then
we already have a client so let's call
this an ell client and in our client
here too and then we don't need this
instance thing documents content okay so
let's we have two different ones so
let's call this one document one and
content equals how do we call it speaker
one transcript and then document two
equals speaker two transcript and then
we'll have test sentiment sentiment one
will be a null client analyze sentiment
document one and then sentiment two will
be an old client analyze sentiment
document - okay and then let's print
sentiment for first speaker score
[Music]
and magnitude and then let's add this
sentiment magnitude and I think this one
would be sent in by one and then we have
another one for sentiment to second
speaker okay let's take okay from here
all of this stuff
and paste it here okay so now you can
see I'm not like faking it this is real
code
okay transcript one transcript - and
there's the score guys cool so this is a
good example if I can do it really
anyone can do it I really you know
welcome you all to try it and combine it
with whatever other API is you want you
know and and we we definitely look too
forward to hearing your feedback about
all these new features we want to make
them better over time so the more
feedback you can share the better okay
so with that let me transition over to
Nicolai from LogMeIn that's going to
take it from here the corporation
products in work mean and every month
millions of customers rely on our
products to run their day to join in
jobs as you can see we have a lot of
audio minutes a lot of meetings and
early on we realized that the meetings
have value before and after customers
need these meetings to write notes to
reference them further to run their
business and what we did is we
introduced recordings and after that we
introduced recording we started to look
at how to make this recordings even more
useful and obvious step was to add
transcription so we started to look for
transcription provider and we selected
Google Google speech text I'm going to
talk about what was the process that we
went through to select Google and but
first I'm going to show you what they
have as a as a UI so this is this is
after meeting you get this a page where
we can share the results of your meeting
and we have a fully searchable UI that
you can search every participant
everything that they said when they say
that you can click on certain pieces so
you don't have to
anymore wait for the entire meeting can
watch it so let's move to a demo this
was a meeting that done and I had a few
weeks ago just to go over a few things
and so let's say we work for we discuss
things like a conference web
conferencing so you can see I can find
every instance of the word conference in
the meeting I can and I can just replace
Rome here so I don't have to wait for so
we were discussing this exact
presentation so how what was the process
for us to select a speech-to-text
provider we were not Google client at
that time we would get all the major
speech-to-text providers we built our
own use cases specifically for what we
do because we wanted to have the best
provider for our use case and what we
selected is the Google Video API we
actually started to work with them when
the API was doing beta and we released
our feature one month after the Google
video API went into production so the
takeaway from here is really really test
and find the best the best provider for
yourself you see these numbers that
providers usually have accuracy but it's
important what works for you how its
implemented we before that we are mostly
Amazon shops so we have our real time
infrastructure on Amazon or on premise
and we have to connect our own
infrastructure with Google so currently
we have a VPC between us and Google and
we combined several data sources we take
all the events that happen in a meeting
when somebody speaks when when he stops
and starts the video streams we send out
you for google to transcription and the
combined result is what you saw on the
screen we can we can identify every
speaker to a word and we can click on
that word and play from them I'm showing
a few code samples probably nothing
surprising for you one thing that we
decided is to build set of services
transcription
parsing of the transcripts as a services
so we can change change the
transcription model even change the
provider if we have to support multiple
transcription results oh so we have this
layer between us and the providers that
we can switch them at any time if we
have to
so the code samples pretty easy one
thing that I want to emphasis is that
it's really important to handle all the
error cases because sometimes food
something like speech to text you can
see way more errors than something like
a regular regular product you have you
have a recording that nobody speaks or
there's starting stuff really quickly so
you can initially you see a lot of
problems that are not problem with the
speech to a speech to text a paper just
how the customers use the product okay
you can see the the results were really
positive we are getting a lot of a lot
on Twitter or other channels we are
getting a lot of positive feedback from
customers we saw that the the usage of
the product are actually going up
because customers are you eyeing on the
on the meeting to be recorded and
transcribed so sometimes they tell us
that they don't even need to take notes
anymore and know that this is recorded
for them and they just go and review
what people said what we are working in
the future will continue to work with
dan and his team better accuracy for
accents when we started to to test it it
works very well for a native speaker
native speakers but it really has a
problem with English with different
accents even accidents like Irish and
not transcribed as well as as English so
we were looking forward for that
multi-language support that's obvious we
support 16 languages we want to
introduce all the languages to the
product and speakers realization this is
very important for us because a lot of
meetings happen from a conference room
and we cannot separate the speakers
using just our infrastructure we have to
use the dilation we started to
experiment we've been using the beta and
again we are applying the same approach
we
going to build our own test cases test
it and understand what what is better
for us okay thank you guys are you doing
my name is Bob McKenna I'm a speech
analytics expert I would talk to you
today about a really exciting project
that I worked on for the last year it's
our own retail basically if you if you
ever worked at retail you understand
that retail stores get a lot of phone
calls from price and availability to
just checking warranty things like that
so one of the things that one of the
projects that have worked on over the
last year worked for two national brands
working on a year-long project we
analyzed over 360,000 retail store calls
which translates to about a million
minutes processed the goal of the
project was to focus on phone call
conversion and this is a big deal
because if you use AdWords or or Bing
ads or any kind of any ads out there
that have location extensions on timer
or clicked a call or Google my business
adds you really want to be able to track
those the the you know the performance
of those ads and that was the the focus
of the project to say hey what is the
conversion of those those calls so using
speech in text api's from google speaker
terrorization models enhanced models the
phone model is the model ended up
picking the natural language processing
for sentiment analysis entity analysis
and then ultimately to connect it all
back to the internal system of the two
brands using the internal messaging bus
google has a pretty good version of this
pub/sub but in this case you actually
used microsoft BizTalk but just a little
bit about the architecture here the
company the partner decided to go with
for for encapsulation of the calls a
dialog tech company out of Chicago great
company basically would happen is a
customer would call the store and
dialogue tech
would post a a do a post call to a cloud
function that would trigger off a number
of events one of those events being
download the the wave file from dialog
Tech into the Google cloud storage which
allowed you to do all the things that
Dan showed you in the demo you can call
that cloud storage bucket from speech
attacks natural language processing a
bunch of other places so working through
that demo and some of the things we were
looking for on the output of that in
bigquery or fuzzy string matching
engrams just the the frequency of words
so demand over time so if a particular
product you can watch the demand over a
year period to say hey is it ramping
during this season or that season or is
it is it declining and that's a really
big deal
you know using bigquery and Python and
some of the packages in Python allowed
us to do that the biggest thing though
that helped out the most was definitely
speaker dilation which allowed us to
separate out the the customer from the
the associate at the store and this
allowed us to do a lot of things from
from a be testing on the the associate
side for training and then engrams and
the fuzzy text matching on the customer
side so we could say hey if they you
know in this particular case in this
call we're looking for phone calls where
they mention the iPhone 7 and whether or
not it was a broken screen or needed a
battery replacement in this case we
wanted to say hey the broken screen we
add that to our list for frequency for
engrams
and then we can also go down through
that using that call caller ID and match
it against the internal system using
that message bus to say hey did that
phone call actually convert into a into
a sale and then if you're getting you
know thousands and thousands of calls a
day you can actually figure out the
value of those phone calls based on that
conversion rate which is I think pretty
revolutionary so I encourage you know
anybody that has a kind of you know a
problem just to keep
working through these api's and and
you'll find a solution some of the other
things that that we could do around that
is the entity and sentiment analysis so
in this case you can see that the
consumer good being an iPhone 7 and you
could see the sentiment score is a
negative point 4 which is which is
negative red because they broke the
screen I'm probably unhappy about that
and they're just trying to get it
repaired and and you can see that in the
the entity in sentiment analysis why we
why we why do we choose you know why we
chose a Google cloud to speech the
accuracy of the transcription with phone
models it was you know we benchmark we
benchmark against you know some of the
major competitors out there amazon
watson IBM IBM watson and the Microsoft
products and we just found consistently
that the transient transcription
accuracy from the Google Texas speech or
in speech to text was a lot it's
significantly better than the other the
other options out there the diary's
ation reliability just be able to
distinguish between the users was a big
deal for us right so between the the
associate and the and the customer that
way we could do training for the for the
the associate and then we could do
conversion on the customer ease of use
we had a lot of a lot of services
already built for using google cloud
services so it was really easy to be
able to connect them all using you know
virtual private network between between
the google cloud platform and and the
internal network and connected to
bigquery and cloud functions so all that
all that you know combined made it a
no-brainer to go with the Google Cloud
speech-to-text product so I'm going to
hand it over to Mahesh and he's going to
talk a little bit about what he's
working on
[Applause]
thanks Bob I'm my astrology I lead the
cognitive computing and data Sciences
lab at cognizant cognizant is a leading
IT service provider its clients across
three lines of services one of which is
digital operations among other things
that we do in digital operations we also
maintain and manage service techs for
customers which brings us a case today
I'm going to talk about today late in q2
of last year I was actually associated
with this engagement client as a retail
chain based out of Australia New Zealand
region the typical challenges where
there was pretty high call volumes there
was long wait times primarily it's a 24
by 7 by 365 set up there the concurrent
calls were average around 20 day Peaks
would hit high 25s season Peaks would
hit anywhere from 45 to 50 right so we
were creating on an average seventy-five
thousand tickets unique ones and if you
add the repeat calls and the overlaps we
were hitting 100 Kaazing and we had
around 1,500 scenarios or cases if you
want to say that we covered as part of
this engagement and because of which it
took a lot of time to onboard even
though we bucketed common scenarios and
trained agents accordingly it did take a
lot of time for us and attrition was not
helping the situation so it was fully
human dependent so there was a very high
cost to it and because of all this see
set score was pretty average right so
giving a view of the process flow itself
users across 3,000 stores Colin from for
issues like printer cartridge not
working to freezer is broken please tell
me what to do that gets to the IVR
system IVR system forwards that to the
agent whoever's free agent listens to it
validates the users request first and
then understands the context and
provides the responses that's that was
the and the user and the agent kind of
did most of the work there so fast
forwarding what we did we still had the
human but he was actually handling only
the exceptions right he replays the
whole human handling all of it with a
bunch of boxes
so now the user calls in from a user
perspective there's absolutely no change
he still calls in a toll-free number
that still has the same idea instead of
going to the agent it actually goes to
the integration framework which is the I
effects abbreviated there that does the
orchestration going forward so we send
that text to Google services get the
voice clip transcribed to text forward
that dialogue flow match the intent get
the response put it back into speech and
give it back to the client and this flow
keeps going back and forth till the
system feels that it has to either
escalate it out or the issues resolved
right so once we put this in place we
immediately saw significant benefits the
average call time dropped from four
minutes to one minute and because of
that the call wait time came down by 20%
straight right the human is still there
in the loop but he's actually handling
the exceptions he's not doing bulk of
the work and because of that the overall
operational costs came down and the
quality of service was consistent and
better the CSAT score by default jumped
up right so if I was going at 2x speed
there's a clock running here and I don't
have time I still have to give you guys
some Q&A time right so that's all Dan's
problem not mine and what did we learn
from all this I thought this is more
important this is where I want to
probably spend time than the previous
context right so don't bother
pre-processing the audio we went through
the exercise of doing that right so as
engineers we jump in to the conclusion
that we have to apply filters for noise
reduction we have to do that do this you
don't have to do them so as a matter of
fact it is counterproductive so if you
apply a lot of digital signal processing
algorithms upfront the output confidence
score is less that's that's what we
figured out so if you have a proper
audio clip send it because the API
already does most of that work for us
right and of course the second one was
the phrase hint so this helped us a lot
in improving the overall score given the
fact that it can take up to 500 words
and if it's domain-specific it did a
phenomenal job of making sure the text
gets transcribed to the
most accuracy possible and the format
sampling and encoding I would like to
add the model also here now that the
three new models being introduced it's
very important when we started off again
the engineering hat kind of comes in and
we say mp4 is a better format it's
compressed we kind of can move data
around quicker and all that but that's a
lossy format right you are better off
compromising on certain items and pick a
lossless format and and lossless
encoding so that the output quality the
final intention of having the audio clip
transformed into text is better so
that's what I would actually suggest and
I'm super excited about the next one
which is the word level confidence
specifically that the case I was talking
to you about so it helps big time right
most of the conversations are short and
you don't have to do a full sentence or
a phrase confidence you can go by the
confidence given by the word or you can
pick and choose the combination to make
sure the dialogue or the conversation
goes forward right of course all the new
things that got introduced does give a
very very natural interaction between
the user it is not IVRS anymore and
that's primarily a big difference if you
are counting the CSAT scores and
interacting so if you are ever on the
other side and if you actually get an
idea response I'm sure all of us hate
that right so that definitely has come
down with the new set of modules that's
been introduced by
you
[Music]